growing up in London in the 1950s was
predictable and dull my generation
demanded new beginning I wanted to be an
actor from the age of 10 birth people
with my background hardly ever became
active so all I wanted was to get a true
cockney character on the big screen and
I got the chance to do it the old rule
books are being torn up and thrown away
everything is dull and gray we want to
come in the permissive society is
considered by some youngsters to be
trendy and with it was the first time
the future was shaped by young people
just the clouds we get around
so always rules how to live and it's
just not true
you didn't hear model sleep but then you
did and they've never shut me up
this isn't the first generations
question the moral values of the last
generations
it was our top
best time of our life
what was it all about I'm gonna show you
[Music]
I wasn't always my cocaine I was Paul
Morris Joseph Michael white my mother
was a child lady cleaner and my father
was a village gate fish market porter I
was expected to follow in his footsteps
but I hated the smell of fish too like
your father because I didn't think
anybody would be left down here yes the
currency we used to pick up our missus
fall as an English child grows he
becomes aware he has already been
assigned a place in a large game a
system has intricate and elaborate as a
maze a maze of tradition outmoded rules
about who should succeed in the eyes of
the establishment discipline is
indispensable to a progressive and
mature society give him discipline in
the home from school in college network
build the foundations for happiness are
well as there
son reviews to share
you